la politique colonisatrice et
israélienne qualifiée d' apartheid l ong
américaine de défense des droits humains
human rights watch l'a désigné de cette
façon dans un rapport est des
organisations israéliennes utilisent
également le terme apartheid depuis
quelques mois pour désigner les
politiques d'israël à l'égard des arabes
israéliens et des palestiniens des
territoires occupés mais c'est la
première fois qu'une importante ong
internationales reprend à son compte
écoutez justement omar chakir directeur
israël palestine à human rights watch
ainsi à que gènes comptent ochowicz
directeur d'un groupe de réflexion
conservateur a jerusalem le gouvernement
israélien réuni aujourd'hui
principalement sur la zone située entre
le jourdain et la mer méditerranée en
eau vive de groupe de taille à peu près
égales dans ces zones le gouvernement
israélien privilégie méthodiquement les
israéliens juifs en les gouvernants
selon un système unique de loi et de
privilèges tout en réprimant
systématiquement les palestiniens divers
degrés d'intensité selon l'endroit où
ils vivent
le raisonnement qui veut que la proche
de la communauté internationale s'agisse
d'une situation temporaire qu'un
processus de paix sera bientôt réglée
occulte la réalité de la domination
discriminatoire et bien ancré d'israël
sur les palestiniens
il est temps d'appeler un chat un chat
de reconnaître la réalité telle qu'elle
est la réalité pour des millions de
palestiniens et l'apartheid et la
persécution
le rapport n'est rien de plus qu'un
document de propagande plein
d'inexactitudes factuelle de déformation
et de réalité entièrement alternative
le rapport va au-delà de ce que même le
président palestinien mahmoud abbas et
la cour pénale internationale ont dit la
semaine dernière encore mahmoud abbas a
clairement indiqué qu'il ne pensait pas
qu israël était un état d'apartheid
la cour pénale internationale qui
enquête sur israël depuis des années n'a
pas conclut-il israël était un état
d'apartheid
ce rapport n'est rien d'autre qu'une
fabrication de fantasmes de déclarations
erronées et de fausses représentations
qui est fondamentalement antisémite
parce qu'il est conçu pour rendre
illégitime état juif
je sais